oh good I'll get some more mileage out
of this jacket so after all of the
rumors and the arguments and the fans
eating each other we have an official
confirmation that hey surprise Jodie
Whittaker is coming back for at least
one more series of Doctor Who now if you
want to be technical this was not an
announcement from the BBC itself but it
was something that Jodie Whittaker
herself did confirm in an in an
interview with I think it was The
Hollywood Reporter I can't remember now
but these those words came directly from
her so if we can now stop all of the
either yo conspirators gonna happen or
campaigning for it to happen for Jodie
Whittaker to not come back for an
another series she's coming back
so digest that however you need to and
let's all move forward now I will note
because if I don't someone will bring it
up in the comments that right now we
don't have a confirmation of Chris
Chibnall returning as showrunner now I
wouldn't have expected now it let me
back up
if the announcement of Jodie would occur
returning for another series had come
from the BBC directly itself like in a
press announcement and they failed to
mention ship Knowles return as well that
would have been a little bit weird and a
little bit suspicious to me because it's
like why would you announce both and
leaving one out time two draws attention
to it but since this is a confirmation
that came from Whitaker herself she's
it's not really her business to confirm
whether or not ship Mel's coming back so
I don't consider that to be any kind of
red flag or indication of anything as to
whether or not he is coming back for
another series whereas under other
circumstances I might put a little
weight in that I'm not going to in this
case given the source of this particular
information so what does that mean well
I mean obvious
I mean here's the thing it would have
been really unlikely unless it was a
fairly long-term plan to replace Jodie
Whittaker that she was not gonna do at
least two series because you know at
this point they've already shot the the
New Year's one and they would have had
to make a fairly hasty decision in terms
of like when the show started airing and
when they were like okay we got a
replacement because they would have
needed the time to write a special that
included a regeneration and that very
obviously didn't happen now does that
mean she'll keep going for this what has
become the standard three series
following her you know following this
next one who knows I'm not gonna
speculate on that but she's not it this
is not gonna be an echo sting case it's
not gonna be a one-off now so for me for
me personally I'm glad for that and it's
not because I love Jodie Whitaker's
doctor I have not fallen in love with
Jodie Whitaker's doctor I don't dislike
her either I don't think she's bad for
the part and I don't think she's doing
anything wrong but I haven't had my fall
in love with this doctor moment yet but
as I have pointed out when I tend to say
that I didn't really completely fall in
love with Capaldi's doctor for a while
like the the moment that I truly came to
start to love him the way I now love him
was not until his second series and it
was a moment that a lot of other people
don't really like so color me weird but
you know she's had little moments across
this first series I'm like oh that's
almost it oh that's almost that and I
was kind of like that with Capaldi
because you know I'm the doctor this is
my spoon I'm like oh that's that is
almost it or or listen which was in his
first series I was like that was it was
almost it but I'm not sure it was in
them what I actually had my moment that
I fell in love with him in the second
series I for and I had it for compares
I'm like oh okay those weren't quite it
this is it so I wanted her to come back
for another fuse cuz I I want to love
her and it's not because I'm like
I want to love the female doctor cuz I'm
supposed to cuz I'm a liberal minded
like know anyone who cos cat-eye I want
to love Doctor Who as a show I always
want to love this show I will never wish
for its downfall or its crumbling or its
cancellation I always want the best from
it and for it so if if I haven't fallen
in love with her yet I want her to take
another chance to try and get me to fall
in love with her because I don't like
having any doctor that I don't love it's
been one of my great joys with Big
Finish is coming to love The Sixth
Doctor cuz I didn't before
The Sixth Doctor was like the flat-out
this guy's no good doctor for me until I
started listening to the audios I'm like
oh my god he can be good and now I love
The Sixth Doctor and I've had my moments
of coming to love him the way that I
love almost every other doctor and it's
I love finding that I love feeling that
that is that is where it becomes
whatever else is going on that's where
it becomes worth it I I will always come
back to the show and I will always want
it to connect and to work for me and the
fact that I haven't fallen in love
completely with the thirteenth doctor so
far to me is you know I take that on a
very personal level because I know there
are other people who have fallen in love
with her so me saying I haven't fallen
in love with her yet isn't necessarily
even a criticism it's just me being
honest about where I stand on all this
as it currently is but that does mean
that you know we can quit the rumors of
she's gone right away the rumors will
still persist about Chibnall until they
confirm that he's coming back but I'm
not gonna give my thoughts on Chibnall
work so far or what may or may not or
should happen with his work in the
future until I do my sort of wrap-up
overview thoughts on series 11 once it
finishes airing so once that is all done
I will I'll do a couple things I will
rank those the episodes from series 11
and set from that I will give my
thoughts on the thing is kind of
looking at the big picture as opposed to
dissecting it episode by episode as I've
been doing as it airs so there we go
Jodie Whittaker she's not leaving what
are your thoughts on it
keep them respectful even if you don't
like this news please whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about a whole bunch
of stuff you can do such as like
subscribe there's a button there's a
link goes to my patreon you want to
support me that way hey if you don't
want to that's ok though because this is
a whole bunch of other links that you
can follow as well and you don't want to
click on those that's ok too because at
the end of the day folks
you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]